there are now 456 people testing  positive for coronavirus that's up from  373 people so an increase of nearly 80  on the same point yesterday those  figures from the Department of Health  and we can get more now from our health  correspondent our she's Joshi on those  latest statistics Ashish yes that's so a  rise in the number of people who have  tested positive of 83 so the total  figure at the moment is 456 positive  cases it was 373 yesterday so up by 83  and the other critical figure in all of  this Adam of course the number of people  have died as a result of coronavirus  remains at six that could well change  but as it stands at the moment still the  six people have died for Corinne a virus